la première question est
je suis content que vous m'ayez posé cette question
quel est votre vrai prénom euh je
préfère garder ça secret
pourquoi ils t'ont appelé mickey
je ne sais pas bien tu as dit que le
homeboy était la chose la plus importante
ce que tu as fait,
je pense que c'était parce que quand nous y
travaillions, il m'a fallu tant d'années
pour le faire,
n'aurais-tu pas préféré être
une star en
tant que boxeur ou dans une entreprise de chaussures oh je
ne suis pas euh
je  Je ne sais pas que je devrais y
penser pendant un moment, je pense que
si quelqu'un est impoli avec votre fille, utiliseriez-
vous toujours vos poings,
pas de boxe ou
[Musique]
cracher sur le show-business, le show-
business
n'est-il pas toujours auto-  destructeur
je ne sais pas
est-ce le vrai willy deville que l'on voit
au début de homeboy
et comment se fait-il qu'on ne le voit plus
euh ce n'est pas le vrai willy deville
que c'était c'était
un imitateur de willie deville
oh tu as passé quatre ans au studio actif
penses-tu que c'est quelque chose que euh
tu peux apprendre je pense si  si vous
y restez assez longtemps peut
-être pensez-vous que vous y êtes resté
assez non je pense que
j'aurais probablement dû y rester
beaucoup plus longtemps entre
brando dean et clifford serait votre
top trois probablement les trois oh
ouais qu'en est-il de l'histoire euh de  jerry
lee lewis que tu prévois de
bien jouer jerry et j'ai eu une dispute et il
ne voulait pas que je le fasse donc
il va le faire c'est parce que tu n'aimes
pas les petites filles
non je ne sais pas jerry voulait faire  il
voulait tout recommencer
quel genre de musique écoutez-vous maintenant les
jeudis
je dors habituellement toute la journée
est-il vrai que depuis que vous avez joué le
dernier film de liliana cavani
saint francesco que vous vivez comme un
moine oui
[Musique]
je  n'est pas sorti depuis hier soir